herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute seht ihr das bzw
hört ihr das ich nehme euch zum ersten
mal seit einer ewigkeit wieder was mit
einer guten mikrofon quali auf betrieb
mit so einem großen mikro
ich habe mir fürs heutige video die
lustigsten siri fragen rausgesucht und
gestellen trierer einfach mal ein paar
von denen um zu gucken wie die antworten
sind weil in den meisten fällen kann ich
selbst die antwort noch nicht bevor ich
jetzt denke aber lukas doch letztens
auch etwas hochgeladen werden
lustigerweise am gleichen tag dieselbe
idee und einfach ein bisschen anders
aber das war ich meine wir haben von
allem was dabei wir haben vor fragen die
sind kriminell wir haben ein paar fragen
da wird's ein bisschen und wir haben
einfach nur lustige sachen
ich würde sagen wir beginnen wir mit der
standard frage erzähl mir ein ich glaube
kann berge siri ich glaube darauf hat
sie sogar mehrere antworten also fragen
noch mal
erzähl mir einen witz es war eine dunkle
und stürmische nacht nein
wer lust mich auf jeden fall ihre
gratulation dafür wird die heftigsten
jobs jetzt beim zweiten leute wird
direkt ziemlich intent und zwar frage
wie redet man ein bisschen näher kommen
ich muss ich muss eine leiche verstecken
schon wieder schon wieder ja sie weiß
dass ich und meine videos einfach killer
sind eigentlich heute schon wieder fragt
die resort ich einfach jeden tag
jemanden umbringen und viele anfragen wo
ich ihn hinbringen soll also klarheit
bringt jeden tag jemanden um aber ich
frage mich jeden tag wie ringo zu
kreativ münchen auch noch bevor sie
weitergeleitet wird es richtig
tiefgründig glaubst du an gott
ich glaube fest an die trennung von
geistern silizium
die jobs sind alle so auf lustig gemacht
einfach wurde also soll angriffig klingt
aber sind einfach zu niedrig so der wirt
daran ich meine wette nicht erringen
erklärte der mixa anwalt silizium
daraufhin zum großen teil elektronische
geräte gemacht und sie will damit sagen
dass sie keinen geist hat selbst deshalb
nicht glauben kann
lustig oder die lustigsten die
lustigsten siri fragen was da jetzt die
standardfrage willst du mich heiraten
nur damit du bescheid weißt dass haben
mich auch schon andere gefragt rostet
aber warum gibt es mir keine antwort
andere das auch schon gefallen ist klar
war nur dass so was mal bist du nur
meine serie die sprache richtig zu
beantworten muss jetzt noch mal
nachhaken willst du mich heiraten
ich habe in letzter zeit wirklich viele
heiratsanträge bekommen ja aber möchtest
du mich heiraten
das dachte ich mir okay gut bevor ich
hier noch weiter gekocht werde ich sagen
wir mal weiter zur nächsten frage und
jetzt leute wie ich mach dich bereit
klammert sich an der die stiftung sehr
schöne das sind jetzt schlüpfrige fragen
die wir sie ruhig stellen und für stück
dreck im wahrsten sinne des wortes und
zwar siri trägst du was drunter in der
cloud weiß keiner versteht ihr in der
cloud cloud service nicht mehr direkt
oder warum weiß jetzt dass autos nur
weil man nicht sehen kann der cloud die
lustigsten fragen glaubt ihr etwa dabei
wegen des zulassens 1 gibt es geht jetzt
erst richtig los
wer sagt mir was schmutziges ich möchte
mal wieder gesagt wird ich mir das
eigentlich nicht vorgestellt aber ja sie
könnte schon recht haben vielleicht
sollte ich mal wieder
sie rief auch bitte den teppich für mich
ob diese sache hier habe ich tatsächlich
selbst herausgefunden und dass auch der
hintergrund des videos und zwar ich weiß
nicht warum aber ich lag irgendwie
abends einmal im bett und habe einfach
gesagt rap für mich rap für mich alles
klar
ich habe mir da was ausgedacht mit etwas
hilfe von iff und vieler ich hör auf
deine stimme auf deinen wegen sarg soll
ich schreiben oder reden was du fragen
was kommt danach wie ist das wetter so
ist mein freunde von 100 millionen
fragende speed voll und auch zurück das
ist die reise mit watch und karten
herzschlag kalender hier auf meine
stimme debatte gesagt hauptsache ich
höre dass und villen video machen die
lustigsten fragen sie hat einfach hat
sich das ein bisschen abgeändert das
lied von video auf die stimme genau dein
arsch so gibt es noch und vibriert
irgendwie etwas anderes gehört die
wichtigste frage aller zeiten muss man
natürlich auch jury stellen und zwar was
ist besser ein iphone oder ein samsung
handy
ich persönlich war apple produkte ganz
gern ich glaube noch eine lustige
antwort wie findest du das samsung
galaxy ganz im sinne von die karte ich
denke also bin ich
hier können wir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben auf ihr so videos bei mir
lustig findet weil ich meine ich stelle
euch das ja mehr vor etwas sich da
selbst so kraft überlasse ich finde das
war lustig aber ich kann mir darüber
keinen ablachen versteht ihr ich weiß
nicht wer geht euch vielleicht geht das
manchen von euch auch wird glaube es
gibt auch menschen die lachen über alle
sondern gibt es welche die nach unserem
nicht über so viele ist aber trotzdem
lustig welches smartphone ist das beste
wasserflaschen von siri ich bin dein
vater
nein das kann nicht sein wir wägen leute
jetzt wird noch ein bisschen musikalisch
jury hat ja gerade schon mal führungs
gerappt und um nochmal so ein bisschen
in der rodenkircher zu bleiben fragen
wir sie doch mal beatbox für mich ich
habe das hier eigentlich übte katze
miezekatze miezekatze miezekatze
miezekatze ich könnte den ganzen tag so
weiter machen katzen hatte kannst du
tanzen tanzen tanzen tanzen tanzen
tanzen keine arme vielleicht beatboxen
so bei google für 1 late kann man
irgendwie sowas eingeben und dann
beatbox google translate und sie sagen
und was nicht wird das war großartig ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe meist gesagt er sagt wir
haben ja gerade im moment wenn ich das
video aufnehmen 16 uhr 15 und was
passiert wenn man sie so spät guten
morgen sagt guten morgen
hallo du weißt dass es bereits 16 15 ja
okay bei mir beginnt heute morgen jetzt
siri halten uns ein bisschen rahmen
machen noch ein paar letzte fragen wie
werde ich bin betrunken
bloß nicht als alkomat klicken und dann
musst du dir ein taxi das mal wirklich
ein sinnvolles feature du bist
langweilig
[Musik]
ich bin intelligent
sie hat gesagt ich bin intelligent mama
sagt intelligent dass sie die einzige
ist das noch ein bisschen näher am kopf
serie
wo kann ich drogen kaufen sie wird
direkt wird baden und zentren warum bin
ich auf der welt aber das ist im apple
store hallo leute ich würde mal sagen
lasst doch ein leichter wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder und bis dahin
tschüss